suis parti pour paris que j ai trouvé
une chambre 14 femmes rendront un
vibrant hommage à pauline julien et si
le bonheur je suis contente parce que
ont d'abord on a pensé à elle de lui
rendre hommage on l'avait un peu oublié
fusion les deux amis mais franchement on
était des amis ce soir
[Musique]
tendres tendres 12 12 la grande
pauline-julien nous a quittés il ya
vingt ans et elle serait sans doute fier
de ce spectacle intitulé la renarde sur
les traces de pauline julien qui a germé
dans la tête d'inès talbi 34 ans né à
montréal de parents tunisiens berbère je
pense que la première fois que j'ai
entendu pauline julien c'était chez une
amie d'enfance rien à sa mère écoutait
beaucoup de musique francophone
québécoise j'avais comme eu un coup de
coeur sur ce qui était en train de jouer
ma maison
ah et l'onudi on se souvient de pauline
julien la chanteuse sophie cadieux se
souvient aussi de la militante d'enduro
chicago jeudi qu'il fluviaux plus
fatigués à 22 ans il dit on est dans une
période où on parle de féminisme et de
mmorpg féminin pour moi c'est une icône
de son engagement aux nourrissons après
les francos de montréal la renarde sur
les traces de pauline julien fera le
tour du québec en 2019
on y rend hommage à une femme dynamique
une femme qui aimait passionnément la
fille qui aimait son pays et qui serait
aujourd'hui vraiment de sont donc les
ter le mans
[Musique]
o o
ans
ici louis fait des primaires radio
canada montréal
[Musique]
ça
retour